en face et on donne quoi fait ça il fait
c'est une grosse fessée qui est qu'est
ce que tu fais toi maman l'a fait c'est
un sujet qui fait débat
avec toujours cette même interrogation
etes-vous pour ou contre la fessée dans
les années 70 la question agite est déjà
les plateaux télé et à l'époque certains
spécialistes recommandent est
ouvertement la fessée pour 7 6 4 par
exemple une bonne tape de temps en temps
aidé parfois remettre les idées en place
c'est tout à fait certains canaux fo qui
est dans une crise agitation notre
seconde fait très bien être
tranquillisés physiquement et moralement
par une bonne tape sur les fesses qui
met fin à ces gesticulations
une théorie que ne partageait pas du
tout cette mère de famille je pense
qu'il ya d'autres punitions la fessée je
crois que c'est surtout au soulagement
des parents plutôt les suédois sont les
premiers à avoir banni les châtiments
corporels sur les enfants dès 1979
depuis une cinquantaine de pays dont la
majorité des pays européens ont suivi
l'exemple mais pas la france
ici la fessée à la vie dure lorsqu'on a
dit une fois deux fois trois fois jérémy
ne fait pas le jérémy le voilà et quand
jérémy va jusqu'au bout et fait je ne
dis plus l'être une quatrième fois je me
fais c est ce que tu comprends comment
malmène fait c'est jérémy et en 2015
c'est au tour de la france de se faire
taper sur les doigts et huit chiens le
conseil de l'europe condamnait le pays
pour n'avoir toujours pas interdit les
châtiments corporels envers les enfants
pédiatre engagé edwige antier se
réjouissait de l'initiative
c'est une grande victoire et je salue le
courage du conseil de l'europe
il faut que ce soit inscrit dans le code
civil
ça veut dire les châtiments corporels ce
n'est pas un geste éducatif
un an plus tard les défenseurs des
droits de l'enfant touchait presque au
but
l'assemblée nationale a adopté un
amendement pour l'interdiction des
violences éducatives ordinaires dont la
pcp partie
mais en 2017 le conseil constitutionnel
évoqué un vice de procédure et rejeter
le texte
retour à la case départ
[Musique]